we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192 David P
uh we got a voicemail from our old
friend Eric from Mass
and he is moving on from anti-vaxx to
anti-trans and he makes some claims
that don't make any sense that I
actually want to spend some time talking
about listen to this they're about trans
kids and gay kids hey David Fell from us
um that was a funny video gay children
trans joke there's no such thing hmm
yeah think back when you were a kid
no such thing as gay children trans
children what do you mean that's an
adult being thing
Maybe 16.
were you running around uh you're gay or
you're running around sleeping with uh
kids when you were eight nine ten eleven
twelve I mean four girls maybe if you
try that once or twice doubt it no such
thing as gay children or trans children
it's ridiculous he will he's moved to
GoPros next it'll be they're trying to
do gay babies now I mean trans babies
three-year-old transition Okay so I I
happen I happen to be heterosexual I I
happen not to be gay but I knew that
at quite an early age
um
my gay friends who I've talked to about
this say oh no I I knew that I was gay
when I was very young most of them say
five or six
um and I think that that I mean as I
think back I think I knew I was
heterosexual at age five or six at least
that's as far back as I can remember
Eric from Mass seems to think that the
sort of default status for everyone is
heterosexuality and at age and and uh
cisgender gender identity meaning that
your gender identity just it aligns with
your biological sex
at Birth until age 16 and suddenly 16th
birthday you go oh you know what
actually I'm gay actually I'm trans and
of course this is ridiculous now there's
a separate question which is a
legitimate question about what age
limits should there be on certain
aspects to transition when we're talking
about medication versus surgical versus
there are all sorts of realistic and
practical good faith questions that
should be explored by the medical
community
about that much like as I say many times
I don't think I have the answers when it
comes to transports on every sport and
any situation I don't I'm not pretending
to have the answer but what I do know is
that the bathroom fear mongering is
actually nonsense what I do know is that
everyone should be treated with respect
what I do know is that calling somebody
by a different name that they want to be
called or using different pronouns is
really no big deal one way or the other
and it almost is boring to me and what I
mean by that is when I say it's boring
sometimes people misunderstand what I
say I don't mean that I don't care about
the plight of folks whose identity isn't
being respected or recognized by Society
that's not what I mean what I mean is
there are so many other issues that I
actively believe we need to work on
inequality wages climate change
education Etc that having to talk about
what pronouns someone wants to go by or
whether they're going to wear a dress or
whatever it's just such a distraction
it's not a distraction to advocate for
people to be treated uh properly and so
I want to make clear that I'm making a
distinction there but this unfortunately
this view that Eric presents here
um when it is believed it leads to
unfortunate treatment of people and this
was an issue you know I remember back in
the the days you know when I would
interview the Westboro Baptist Church
people this is like 10 over 10 years ago
now and gay marriage was like the big
battle line on um issues of sexual
orientation and gender you had this
argument people are either born gay or
uh it is a choice that was often the
dichotomy and what underlied that
argument was often that some folks
asserted if it's a choice we should be
able to treat LGBT people like crap
because they're merely choosing that
sort of like you might choose to be goth
or whatever the case may be and what was
often lost there was
even if it were a choice of which for
which there is no evidence but even if
it if even if any of these things are
choices
why would we treat anyone like crap why
would we discriminate against anybody uh
as a society it still doesn't make any
sense and that's much of what underlies
this sort of thing with people like Eric
from Mass and uh and others which is if
they they think if they can convince
society that all of these identities are
merely things that people choose in
their teens either for attention or
because they believe it's mental illness
or whatever then as a society we would
be free to treat these folks terribly
and that's maybe the saddest part of it
all because we shouldn't be treating
anybody like crap I think is the
takeaway that I want to go to so another
disturbing voicemail from Eric from Mass
that serves as an insight
into what is malfunctioning in the
brains of many of these anti-trans
people we've got a great bonus show for
you today I can't wait for it
um target has decided to remove some of
their pride month merchandise after
receiving threats yeah they seem to be
capitulating secondly social media is
driving the Teen Mental Health crisis
the Surgeon General is warning as if we
didn't already know that but we have
even more data now that we're going to
look at I'm actually going to tell
people about now having a baby even
though we're nowhere near this phase I
have been thinking a lot about what is
my policy going to be on social media
and smartphone use and Cal Newport has
an interesting episode about this on his
podcast recently Jonathan height has
talked about it a lot to talk about and
lastly there is a new survey whose
results are surprising to some which
finds that veterans are less likely to
support extremist movements of any kind
there's often the assumption that
military vets are more extreme
politically but the survey suggests
something different we're going to look
at it of course it looks at averages all
of those stories and more are on today's
bonus show which I invite you to access
by signing up at joinpakman.com or
making a pledge on patreon at
patreon.com the davidpackman show bonus
show coming up today new show tomorrow
will do the aftermath of the DeSantis
announcement and so many other things